coming back to the paper let's have a
look at part b
this eigen diagram shows uh two complex
numbers his z
and his w and they both lie on the
circumference of a circle
that is centered at the origin and then
you get asked to prove this particular
geometric result down here that relates
the argument to z so you can draw that
in and the argument to r w
which you can also draw in to the
argument of z plus w which isn't on our
diagram
yet now i said this before um and i
promised i wouldn't drone on about it
but i feel like it needs to be restated
um because this is such a geometric
visual
problem if you tried to solve this
solely algebraically and several people
did trying to you know do stuff with tan
inverse and all that kind of thing
you almost never got anywhere in fact i
think i can say for all of the responses
that i read
um you made very little appreciable
progress so i think it is important
anytime you see a diagram and you get
asked to make some kind of argument or
proof where you need to talk about the
visual elements and how they
relate to each other geometrically draw
a diagram
draw a big diagram draw a clear diagram
and then
use that as your mechanism for
communicating
your own logic that was crucial all the
best answers did it
and uh many people suffered for trying
not to do it
i know diagrams take a long time to draw
but i feel
it is time that you cannot like you
don't have time not to draw a diagram
which sounds weird right but
without a diagram you're just feeling
around in the dark i've got two
solutions for this to show you
as is often the case with geometric
problems there's more than one path
through the question
and there's even more than the two parts
that i saw here but these are kind of
the most
obvious ones the first one is to
use a rhombus now i mentioned before on
the original diagram in the question it
provides a z
and a w but z plus w which obviously
because arg z plus w is the left-hand
side of the result we're trying to prove
it doesn't exist on the diagram so you
need to place it there
and of course the more accurate you can
make your diagram
which by the way it's easier to make an
accurate diagram when it's a big diagram
the more accurate you can make it the
more you can see the intrinsic geometry
that's going on here
you're creating a rhombus not just a
parallelogram
because z this is uh the interval that
represents that complex number z
and w here's the corresponding interval
because they both are radii on the
circumference of that circle
centered at the origin that's why you
get and i've i've labeled these
um a and oc they have to be equal to
each other because
they're radii have a circle since those
two are equal to each other you can see
to get to z
plus w i do the z uh vector as it were i
go oh a
and then i go uh a b that's that a b
is equivalent to adding w on because
it's the addition of those two vectors
there so
that's why you can see up here i get
this parallelogram like i always do
whenever i add any pair of complex
numbers
but it's the special kind of
parallelogram where all of your signs
are equal because of those radii that i
mentioned earlier
so you can see by the parallelogram law
i've got this parallelogram
i make the argument that i've got radii
which gives me the fact that it's a
rhombus because all the sides are equal
and the reason why i go towards having a
rhombus is because
rhombuses rhombi however say that they
have particular geometric properties
that are useful to me
i might have seen it when i just
scrolled by but have a look over here
back on the question
i have to relate this angle here z plus
w
to half of these other angles here when
they're added together
when you're halving an angle that is
another way of saying visually you're
slicing it in half you're bisecting it
right
so that's why you can see here i have
this ob
which i've deliberately used to cut that
diagram or that angle rather in half
that you can see here
because diagonals bisect
angles in a rhombus several people said
that diagonals
bisect angles in parallelograms which
it's really easy to see give a counter
example of this fact if i were to draw a
parallelogram like
this and then
draw one of the diagonals like so
you can clearly see there's going to be
a big part
of that corner angle and then there's
going to be a little part
of that corner angle so this is no dice
right
you can't just say i'm going to always
bisect the corner angles with a diagonal
you need to have a rhombus in order to
establish that so that was a minor point
that several people
mistook now what i've got here is
aob is half of aoc so let's have a look
at what's going on here
aob is i better make this a bit finer so
you can read it a bit more clearly
like so let's get on to the next
solution here's aob
right in here and i'm saying that it's
half of aoc which is going
all the way across here so you can see
there's
aoc and the orange angle you can see in
here is
has been it's half it's got either side
there because of that diagonal bisection
and the thing about that angle there
this purple angle you can see
it starts with arc w but it's not
including this teeny tiny little bit in
here see that
it's like w we've subtracted that red
piece there
but that red piece is arg z because it
is the argument from the real axis
all the way up until i'm pointing at z
so that's why
this angle here in purple might as well
highlight that that is going to be
[Music]
that's aob but it is half of our w
take away remembering that arg z is that
little red angle that i was
subtracting in the first place now that
gives me a half which is very helpful
i'm like oh good this is
on the right track but it's not a half
of the angle that i actually want if you
go back to the paper
let's sort of whoops it easy there's my
finger if you have a look i've got arg z
plus r w whereas what i've got in my
brackets are
w minus r z so clearly i have more work
to do
so coming back to my diagram here i
haven't related arg of z
plus w yet to these other angles so i
can say where's r of z plus w
it's this angle in here from let's
choose another color
from the positive real axis all the way
up to pointing at z plus w which you can
see
up there so how do i form that angle
well you can see it's going to be this
red angle
plus that orange angle that i just
mentioned which i already determined is
half
of our w take away arg zed so red angle
arg zed plus orange angle which i just
determined
um i'm going to have oh i think i've
colored that
wrong that should be orange let's fix
that shall we
sorry team uh ao
aob aoc was the purple angle let's make
that a little bit better
that's better sorry if that's confusing
okay so where am i up to i've got
this this part here this is aob like i
determined before so that's that angle
that i got from bisecting
the angle in the corner of the rhombus
and then i've got this little
tiny angle in here the red angle so
let's highlight that there's arg
zed so i've added that on but i've got
like terms right you can see here
there's some arg zed's there and there's
an augzit
there so they become this when
they are simplified collected together
and you can see that's pretty much it i
just have to take that factor of a half
out and i am home so you can see there
were some clear steps there i needed to
work out what arg
of z plus w was but being able to do
that is clearly related to augzeit
and our w independently and i use the
appropriate geometric
properties in order to prove that
so as promised this is not the only way
to solve this question
as is often the case with geometry
problems we've got many different
techniques
many different pathways through this
question so the
the solution i'm about to show you is
not as neat and succinct as this one
but often the first solution you come up
with is not the most efficient path and
that doesn't mean it's wrong it just
means it'll take you a little bit longer
so let's have a look at method two
i've called this one angle sums because
there's a whole bunch of
you know angles i'm going to add up
together i'm not using the same
geometric properties that i did before
in order to solve this so
how do i begin i've described i've
called this point here which is
represented by the complex number
zed i've called that capital a i've got
capital b
up here and then i've also added this c
such that
it goes in the positive real direction
which makes it parallel to the positive
real axis now the reason why this is
handy for me is because
it gives me a pair of parallel lines
i've got a transversal here o
a which gives me co-interior angles on
the inside if you have a look at my
first line of working here underneath my
constructions oac which is which is in
here i'll just mark that in
orange there's angle oac
that is cointerior to arg z over here so
that means they're supplementary
they add up to pi radians so you can see
that right there
just rearranging to make oac the subject
i've got
oac being pi take away
arg zed okay so that's fine with me
and then i can say in order to work out
the angle on the other side
of this ac parallel line i can say well
this angle bac
right think about what bac is it's from
a it's like you're looking up at
b from the perspective of a
now think about what that means for a
second right if i'm measuring from here
up to here there's a direct way to write
the argument from
from one point to another right if i
said to you
what is the arg of say
z what i mean is that's really the
argument of z
from the origin that's the origin is
your point of reference right
in the same way i can say what is the
argument of this point up here z plus w
but i'm not measuring from the origin
i'm actually measuring from over here
which is
z right so instead of writing z
as the as the first thing i'm going to
write z plus w and instead of writing
the origin
0 as the second piece i'm going to write
this z that's where that's my reference
point okay
so you can see that's what i've written
in here which takes a second to
interpret if you think about this right
z plus w that's where i'm measuring 2
and z is where i'm measuring from so
this is a bit of a funny way to write it
but what's great about this is it gives
us very quickly because of
the algebra in here the z's cancel which
just leaves you with arg
w so rather rather indirectly you can
see that this is r
w and another way of saying that is
you've got these two
lines here o to w and then
z to z plus w because they are parallel
you've got these two lines
here they're going to give you as it
were
sort of like corresponding angles if you
want to think about it that way because
i've got arg
w also being there so um if you if you
can see
where i'm constructing that those two
angles that's another way of seeing why
rw appears
all the way over here even though w is
over here
okay so i've got r w here i've got pi
minus r z
over here and what that enables me to
find is this angle
left in here can you see that it is the
final angle left
in this kind of revolution and angles at
a point
add up to 2 pi radians so you can see
that's where i go here
right oab plus oac plus bac these are
the three angles we just found
oac was the orange one o
a b was the purple one and then b a
c is this one oh sorry i think i got
that order wrong
i think b a c is the purple one there we
go that's better
and then o a b is this one that i've
just
drawn in here which is in red which i
don't know that's my unknown okay
so that's the one here that i'm trying
to find and you can see it appears here
i've just done this substitution there's
oac
and there's bac which i just determined
on these lines above so from here all i
need to do is to get everything on the
right hand side except for oab
because that gives me this inside angle
inside this uh this triangle
up in here so i've just used the angle
sum at a point it's a revolution 2 pi
radians and i'm about to use another
angle sum but this time it's not at a
point
it's going to be a triangle how do i get
there
well by vector addition you can see a b
a b
here to get from z to z plus w i'm
adding w
right so that's what tells me that these
two sides here can be considered
as vectors with the same direction and
also the same
important for me the same magnitude so
they're not just parallel they're the
same length so these two
are equal and that means that i've got
this
uh isosceles triangle in here triangle o
a b is isosceles so therefore
these two corner angles here and i need
a new color
let's use this one here this angle in
here
and this angle in here are my base
angles as it were
and so they're going to be equal to each
other as all base angles in our cells
these triangles
are so that's why you can see i say
equal angles are opposite equal sides
in that triangle this is a nice way to
say base angles in an isosceles triangle
equal because it's also true even if
you've got an equilateral triangle
and so now i'm just going to put all
these three angles together from within
that triangle right
aob aob
is this one in here and that's going to
be useful to me because it will get me
to
r z plus w which is the whole point of
this exercise
so aob and [ __ ] they're the same
and so you can see i substitute aob and
[ __ ]
for double aob because that's what these
two combine into
so let me put it like where was my color
there
let's choose oh yeah i used this screen
didn't i so here's
aob and [ __ ] and they become
double aob i already knew what
oab was it was that angle that i worked
out just up here
using the angle sum of the point and
everything here equals
pi because uh the angles in a triangle
all that up to 180 degrees
um from here i just need to make a ob
the subject
and this result right here should be
familiar because i addressed it in my
previous proof the one that i used
a rhombus for because i was bisecting
that angle in the corner that you might
recall so at this point
i'm kind of equivalent to my previous
solution and so now i can just say
i can add these two angles together aob
that i just worked out before
and xz which is just underneath it so
here's aob
and here's xz underneath it that will
give me the angle
up to z plus w arg of z plus w
so this part flows exactly like it did
before
the only difference is that i never had
to appeal to any properties
of a rhombus to be able to prove it this
time bit longer
but we still got there